this program is brought to you by Emory
University idiot is definitely the
region's leader intellectually and
socially and culturally and politically
it has for one thing it has the largest
population the largest middle class the
most educated public population it had a
long history of a liberal democratic
governance through the first part of the
failure of the 20th century so Islamist
came as a reaction to sort of the
militant secular regimes that failed to
deliver on the promise of development of
political stability and economic
development I don't think that the
answer is in shutting Islamist out of
politics I think that the answer is in
giving Islamist as take in stable
peaceful democratic contestation and
have put them to the test I think they
benefit when they are suppressed and
operating from underground whereas if
they are exposed to the public sort of
scrutiny of democratic debate they will
be seen to have nothing to offer the
article 2 of the Egyptian Constitution
says Islam is the religion of the state
and Sharia is the primary source of
legislation now that was put in by the
same authoritarian regimes to try to win
sort of to play the so-called Islamic
art as for a bid to for popular pub
legitimacy and it has no really
significant meaning as state cannot have
a religion to say that Islam is the
religion of the state is a contradiction
the religion is a political the state is
a political institution religion is for
people not for as a political
institution to have the preceding
program is copyrighted by Emory
University